[Music]
hey what's up sean cannell here with a
bonus episode on the think marketing
podcast
all about how to quickly create a
digital product
that you can sell by doing a simple
three to five day challenge now i'm
excited about talking about this because
in our community
so many people want to create an online
course or a digital product but they
honestly
get so overwhelmed and bogged down in
the details
and so i wanted to give you a model that
you can implement based off the last
episode
of the think marketing podcast all about
challenges and if you haven't listened
to that one definitely check it out it's
the podcast episode before this where we
talk all about
doing a three day a five day challenge
it could be about overthinking
it could be about marketing it could be
about learning software learning a skill
whatever your niche is it's helping
people solve a problem or a pain point
and maybe
eventually you want to create a mini
course or an online course
but you're like man how do i outline it
how do i structure it how do i schedule
it
and i want to solve that with a very
simple
method that you can implement really
soon
to accomplish that goal now today's
episode
is brought to you by
startyourmovement.live that's actually a
challenge on how to do challenges by my
friend pedro adeo and i'll tell you a
little bit more about that
but here's the idea i want you to think
about what is a
three to five day challenge that you
could do in
your niche and possibly think about
actually
interviewing people could you do it or
having a guests
for your challenge now one of the
challenges my friend pedro does
it's called the wisdom challenge now he
does 31 days i do not suggest that's a
lot
that's a grind man that's a whole month
of he doesn't even take a day off like
it's it's a lot of content
but what he actually does it's called
the wisdom challenge it's based off the
book of proverbs
and actually what he does every day is
just reads through
the book of proverbs that chapter for
that day
with a guest and talks about some of the
insights and kind of does like a little
bible study
but he schedules guest speakers that are
other authors pastor speakers
and one of the things that he connects
to that challenge
is it's a free challenge but if you want
to buy the recordings
if you want to buy vip and get the
recordings for life
it's 31. well now think about it once
the
challenge is over you now have a bundle
of resources as well
that you can continue to market and sell
in the future
so consider this our friend ben is doing
an intermittent fasting challenge and
of course he's going to teach that
content himself
but imagine if you invited different
authors that can talk about how the body
processes glucose and digest food and
what not
and you were to do a three day challenge
with three guest speakers and you're the
main host and you just invite three
people that are authors or speakers or
experts
and you sell the recordings for even 10
bucks
for seven bucks for 27
not only here's the model what you're
going to do is people can
opt in for a free challenge and on the
next page
you just say hey would you like the
recordings for life
would you like to be able to have access
so that you don't just get these for a
limited time but you actually
get these powerful conversations
um forever and you get kind of a digital
product
of the recordings of this challenge
not only is it a cool way to generate a
little bit of money right up front but
again you now have an
asset that you can use in the future
and so when you think about it one of
the ideas we want to do here at think
media of course our main thing is
youtube but there's things we want to do
about leadership and my thought was
man what are a couple authors we could
invite you know leaders
authors speakers we'd love to have john
maxwell or you know for us that's kind
of more on the faith side maybe like
have
john revere talk about how to multiply
or you know
different people like that so imagine if
we could get those
speakers to be a part of a three-day
challenge or five-day challenge
and it's free but then it's like hey do
you want the recordings or 20 bucks
and there's all that high value and then
maybe you get the transcripts or you get
some other things
my friend you could quickly create uh
it's not really an online course but if
you structure it and even create an
outline to your challenge
you could quickly create a digital
product an asset that you have for sale
now if you do a youtube video let's use
the leadership analogy
you do a youtube video about leadership
and you say hey by the way
you know if you enjoyed this content or
you play a clip from one of those
speakers
that taught for 45 minutes in your
challenge you play a clip
on your youtube channel for seven
minutes pop on camera and say hey
that was a recording from our you know
recent five-day leadership challenge if
you
you know want to grab all those sessions
the challenge is over now but we have 50
off on the recordings and uh you can
grab those for 10 bucks link in the
description down below now you might be
asking a million questions
how do i set that up i mean where do you
host your challenge where does all that
happen
and we just this is not the place for
this bonus episode on the podcast
but i would recommend if you see the
possibility and power of this
uh two things number one if you haven't
listened to part one yet about
challenges go listen to part one
on the think marketing podcast number
two i encourage you if this is
fascinating to you
and you think this could align with your
niche your brand your vision or even
you're like
that sounds cool i want to learn more
then go to startyourmovement.live
because my friend pedro is breaking down
how to do
challenges like how do you set up the
pages how do you you know
do exactly what i described set up an
upsell or
the ability to upgrade to vip when do
you deliver
on that how do you host those files what
do you say in the channel what makes a
good chat
how do you name a challenge how does
what's the difference between a
challenge that succeeds in a challenge
that fails i know you might have a
million questions
and so check out startyourmovement.live
to be a part of pedro's training that's
where we learned
about challenges and i really want to
encourage you the shortest path
to i believe having a digital product
that you can continue to market and sell
and serve your community with
is possibly doing a three-day challenge
forget interviewing
just teach three steps of your thing of
how you help people
in that three-day challenge and then
package and promote
those recordings by putting it on the
calendar it'll
force you to put that out into
the world to get it recorded and then
you can package it and do whatever you
want
with it in the future check out the show
notes if you want more info
and definitely rate and review the
podcast if you've been getting value
out of the think marketing podcast and i
can't wait to see you on the next
episode or hear you or you'll hear me
and heather and i will be back for our
main
tuesday episode but i hope you got value
out of this bonus one and until then
keep crushing it keep smashing it
and we will talk soon
you